Ohhh
Uhm...
Game, I'm not this short. There's a height discrepancy going on. I'm- I'm- I'm quite tall actually...
Okay, hello everybody!!! My name is Markiplier, and welcome to VR Kanojo
Now for the record...
I'm not playing this game for you. Just because I want to see...
[ZOOM IN]
somethin (yes you do)
You see, I'm not a... pervert...
(maybe reconsider)
I'm not playing- that's not what this game is about, this game is a VERY authentic faithful recreation about being alone...
in a girl's room...
With these hands...
With t h e s e  bad boys right here.
Let's just start from the beginning because I got nothing else to do about this
And uhm.. I want to meet you soon. So do I, so do we, so do me. I do too. Just as a perfectly professional
Uhh
Courtesional[?] relationship
I think those are the words
I think- I'm pretty sure I said words there, yeah. Where am I? In relation to you guys. Yeah, okay-
*japanese female voice*
Okay, I'll go make some- Who? No, I'm du-
Don't call me mom...
Hmm.
Hmm...
Uh-huh, okay
Now that's some sweets, okay, all right. I don't like sugar in my teeth
Maybe some honey ooh, all right 'kay. I'm behind the chair now
I-
Hi? Knock knock knock?
*beeping*
How do I
How do I... move? how do I move?
*suggestive movements*
These toasty bad boys here need to know how to move.
I'm gonna look at ya. Oh.
Okay, I looked at you real good.
Oh, I'm in a cactus. Hi hello
"Please open up."
I guess I walk over but I'm gonna hit my.... Yeah. Oh, I'm gonna-
Hang on my desk is-
Hang on. I gotta
OOO that's outside of my range of motion lady
I THINK THE SCALE'S A LITTLE OFF
Hope I don't hit nothing...
grab it, just like that, okay. or not OR NOT or not. Okay. What, would- oh.
I just got a look at it. All right well then I thought that- hey. Oh hello. You're very tall-
and b o u n c y [WHAT??]
uh-huh
You're welcome, did you just tell me to come on in when I'm already in here?
Uh-huh
No, I'm good here, I'm good here.
Here in the land of morality where I'm not...
Stop blonking- okay, all right well. Let's just do that, okay never mind then!
Are you trying to yell at me, I'm literally-
Six to eight thousand feet away from you, the perspective is a little off here. listen, baby. We're gonna
Have a standoff here, and I'm gonna take these toasted puppies
And I'm gonna show you what for if you think you can tell me what to do, okay?
Okay I did it. I would like to reiterate that. I'm just here for study only if you think anything else is gonna happen
I'm gonna show you what for
I GOT A GIRLFRIEND [oh really?]
The first times a boy ever been in my room
Kind of embarrassed so don't stare. What do you what do you *stutters* just what how do I how do I can... convert?
[reads more dialogue]
I- I don't even understand your language how am I gonna be able to help you with a book. Please tell me uh?
NOOOOOOOO
Uh-uh no hold on
But no means no tall lady
NO MEANS NO
Lady. There's one big green book and noth- okay
Alright. I don't like- I don't like the- I don't like these choices. What does the fan do with the fan? Oh?
Oh-
Op sorry, sorry
[Good job Mark for covering hahaha]
Sorry?
Sorry? Sorry ma'am, I'm sorry. Oh what a startling experience how horrible?
I might have psychic powers lady. giant, giant lady
Lady I can't read that what do I even call you? What's your name?
Possession with the correct. Oh this isn't even a language is so blurred
That's probably what it is
I'm gonna go with yeEeEah, that's right
hoohoo
Uh-huh
Okay all right
Whatever you say lady whatever you say oh
I don't like the way she looked at my hand
[Mark's disgusted?]
NO, NO
NO!
oh no
Why are your legs glowing? Why is your crotch glowin- Why are your arms glo- Why? RUN AWAY!
I want to run!
Okay all right. Uhm-
Uhh-
OH NOOOO
[DILEMMA HAPPENS]
*coughs*
Good job buddy, sorry
Well done
Haha, yeah me too, buddy there there well, let's get back to studying huh good pal
So- sorry sorry sorry what about one of these *air punch* no
Oh my gosh. She's immune
Follow my hand
Follow my bit baboo baboo baboo does it hurt when I do this? Oh?
Uh oh
Hello is anybody home. How are your cankles your cankles good?
sugu time dated
You're quite beautiful may I fondle your bottom?
Humbe kudesta indeed that's what they all call me in high school
Nope sorry alright. I'm just doing this for the sake of you know
Okay I'm out of here sorry (x1) I'm out of here.
This has just gotten a little too intimate here. I'm just here for a nice study session
We got a big exam coming up in a few days. I don't feel comfortable here!
Alright, let's get back to studying. Sorry. I touched you
So that has to mean
You you do what you gotta do, I don't know what kind of w- oh you're so tall. that's that's pretty Oh, No
Okay alright, we don't need to see yo- That's a little weird i'm visiting and you're just gonna take a okay
Ah
Alright
Well I'll just leave then ah nope okay alright well, this is um
(notices the thing) Nope nope put that over there
Okay, alright
That's all so it's back alright. Hello friend. Um. Can you just uh?
How are your cankles are you trying
ARE YOU SLEEPING?
No ma yeah, that was my other nickname, how is your elbow?
You got to take care of your joints um lower lumbar doing all right?
Cuchie Cuchie!
Why are you jiggling when you sleep? Also who sleeps like a corpse like that? lady lady lady?
Good well done get a nice pat on the shoulder
There you go, that's good. Go get him sport. Just where are you guys we're can I explain this too all right, so?
This game is an educational experience about
Japanese culture, we learned what the capital of Japan was
Probably okay, all right. You know what?
Go get them chimp
Go get them champ go get them champ go get them champ go get them champ go get them champ
You got it champ good. Well done. Okay. Good. All right? How's them? Cankles all right. Good cankles all right?
I'm out of here. Okay. Thank you. I wish I didn't do this
I'm not gonna be able to explain this one away. This one's getting be demonetized in record time
This one was demonitized before I even uploaded it fancy that okay. Oh nap time over okay?
You lit
You have a guest over you're just gonna fall asleep Hey
I
Came over to study we have an exam! IN TWO DAYS!
Lady
Wake up was this even do how- how them cankles?
That feel good on your cankles
Look, I'm just gonna clip through your bed a little bit. I got to get the other cankle
I'm very thorough when it comes to cankle uh
problem solving
So go out Yama, no indeed how's them elbows you taking care of your joints your shoulder all right?
Just give it a between friends or rather complete strangers all right does it hurt when I do this oh?
Okay all right. Hope we had a good nap
That was awfully nice
For you not necessarily for me
I don't I don't understand what's going on here am I supposed to fall in love with this lazy... lady
Okay
You're still so you didn't even sleep
Okay, alright stret, okay?
That doesn't make any sense don't just don't do whatever you're doing just please don't
How many?
HOW MANY SIT-UPS CAN YOU DO?!? what in the world is this the right time for this LADY? in what world are we just oh?
It's set up a clock you
You can't even do three leaving what kind of person goes I'm sleepy. Oh time for sit-ups that doesn't make any sense at all
Okay, we don't need any of this we don't need it. What are you a baby?
Nope nope you know what we're gonna go with the big old nope I worked out written. You didn't
So it does so we didn't even study we learned one thing
You found something nice time to eat I am NOT where you think I am
Literally no one eats like that lady
The fuck is wrong with you
No I don't want any I don't like this idea. Nope don't like this idea nope
No, no, I'm not coming to an inch closer to you lady. You know what I'm gonna leave you hanging on this one
I'm gonna let's go. No I'm gonna leave you hanging
Sorry, yeah, no no, thank you. No. No. Thank you lady
You just shove it all inside your mouth
Eating sweets made me thirsty. I think I'll have some water. You don't need to narrate your life to me
What the fuck is that about?
As soon see how long she can chug this water alright. We're going for a world record chug
Okay
What why are you looking under the desk, I don't know cuz it's not what I that's not what
No way alright
You oh, no you spilled water on yourself, please do something was it's delightful bog. What is that? What is that?
Oh come, okay. I'll go with the cup option
I'll do my best lady, but so long as we can get back to studying
Because I take my education seriously as you obviously do not
Cup
Bog okay, goodbye bog. Okay looks like it ran awa- It sure did lady. Can you please get some clothes on?
All right, well don't that's not it's one step. What the fuck
Yeah, okay cover your shame lady
Okay
Turn that way
You got it lady. You got I'm all about this
I believe in
Something I can't cross here there we go. I believe in Band polite
Listen lady. We're just gonna get through this together. Okay. We're gonna get through this. We're gonna study. We're gonna pass this exam
We're gonna continue on to college everything's going to be great
Why are you breathing in my ear like that oh?
Okay, all right yeah, okay, I thought oh all right, then excuse me while I turn away
Okay, turning Russell Russell. I don't know okay, nope let's see looking away
That's a lot of zippers on a skirt you don't need to breathe like that lady. You really don't
Sounds like a personal problem nothing. I need to worry about I've got my studies if I had them
Could I help no?
Let's go with the big old nope can't do it. I'm sorry
I can't no there's no human way I could possibly do this I'm gonna leave now. Let's this just leave
I'm fucking out of here I
Am fucked out of here
Come closer, what did I just do all right? Well, I guess I gotta come closer. Oh boy
Okay lady. Oh
I'm closer now. Okay. You are so tall you are very what am I unhooking?
Can I feel it?
No, I can't this is a simulation. I can't actually feel anything in this game. What are you truck? What are we doing?
What are we doing?
Okay, you know what oh how them cankles your cankles good. Is this the hook is
The hook near your cankles hup! boop! doopy! sorry sorry thought the hook was inside your a noose
Had to check there there good job champ. You are so tall you're you're a freaking giant
What are you six foot eight? Oh my god, okay unhook?
What am I unhooking? I'm really trying. I'm giving it the scooping motion. Let's trick that well. That's not right
Mott's coochie I got you all right if I comb it you know like a petting fashion
Nope, that's how isn't how is that working? I don't understand what you're trying to get me to unhook
What am I doing? What am I... doing? You're just so fucking tall where's the massager here we go
Let's really oh, oh wait hang on. Let's really stab this India is this unhooking it
Is that unhooking it is that that is that unhooking it? How'd your cankles?
Your cankles okay? All right whatever, then I'm just gonna keep grabbing violently until I get something what am I unhooking?
What am I unhooking I'm leaving now. Okay? Goodbye
I don't even understand what remotely I was trying to do there. It didn't work, and I feel worse for it
How are your cankles your cankles? Okay? Okay? You're welcome
What the fuck are you what what are you doing is it flop like a fish time my heart why
Nope it's getting hard to breathe. What's it sounds like we should go to the hospital Jesus?
Okay
Nope
Nope, no no no no. I'm not consenting this
No, I wanted to study my concerns are my studies your cankles and your joints
oh
You're so warm do not touch me dude. Do not touch me. I have a girlfriend. I'm fine, please
Kiss it the set of all right then I am uncomfortable
You feel so nervous hehe
Nope
Nope, this is hard pass hard pass on this one. You know where's my escape can I turn on the fan welp
Blanc Blanc Blanc um how's your phone can I your bags?
Wop no no no no no oh
You perv oh now. I'm a perv, okay
Oh, well Oh
God
If you eat fan is that good for you?
Sorry, just trying to feed you your daily dose of fan
Just shove this down your it's like a Pocky here you put this in your gob, and oh look mom
It's like lady in the trap one one one
oh
God the slurping
Yeah, I want to do this again. No once was enough and that was with a fan in the way
Okay all right then oh
All right, well we
Did that the black monster appears?
What the fuck is that oh?
The bog oh, okay, no can't do something you're left to your fate. Okay
Well that was an educational and enlightening
Experience unlike anything I've ever seen before I'm so glad that I went through that what we learned was this is the first game
That's actually been able to replicate my accurate height
Number two I am
Uncomfortable in situations where I am alone with women
number three I am an expert on the health of
Cankles and joints so if you have any questions about that. Ask me in the comments below. I'll answer as best
I can thank you everybody so much for watching and as always I'll see you in the next video